all right part two part two because all
right this lady I think she's supposed
to be a Christian lady I have a feeling
she's divorced I don't
I'm gonna I'm gonna look I'm gonna look
I'm just gonna I'm gonna assume let's
see married or not married I don't see a
husband
you know I'm not gonna go personal it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter I just
have a feeling okay so
working out a one single instance of
cheating is one thing although I
personally believe that anyone who would
cheat once would 100 be willing to do it
a million times more because they're
showing a sociopathic level of disregard
for their Partners mental emotional and
spiritual well-being do you see it how
she immediately takes the woman's side
there's no Nuance there's no
he
obviously was just being a bad man
he obviously there was no reason when a
lot of these guys if you ask them she
wasn't sleeping with him and then it's
so crazy because then then their first
response is well well
oh oh well she wasn't asleep well he
should have just left then and you're
like well he's kind of in a
a pretty bad contract where he loses
everything well he should have just left
well you know that we can't give him
anyways okay so she's immediately
there's no well what did the woman do
like there's never any did she
contribute it's always oh the man is
evil okay tolerating constant sexual
abuse by being cheated on regularly
should not be accepted by anyone least
of all Christian women do you see how
women today are just of a Different
Cloth I'm telling you Grandma's
great-grandmothers great great
grandmothers you could talk to them
about this stuff they would tell you to
work it out but the women today are just
that we're not of the same cloth we're
not like
especially we know that sex for men and
for women is different all right so to
act like a man Can't Screw some random
girl and you can't get over it it's just
it's not true now guys is this me saying
cheating is okay no wrong it is wrong
wrong but
if we're gonna say a quarter to half of
all marriages this is the reason
are we really going to pretend that the
women are just innocent in this okay
ideally of course all Christians will be
born into healthy Christian parents who
don't abuse one another in any way
okay so if we're gonna say that the men
are abusing
the women for that what about the women
even even if it's not sexual she's a
social media person well social media is
inviting attention from other men
I'm just saying I hope your cloth is
clean or whatever they say
um okay
is much worse
um women to stay with their abusive
Partners is much worse than children
growing up in a single mother home wrong
I mean the data on that wrong okay one
let's not call cheating abuse cheating
is not abuse let's disconnect that is
wrong that is like and this is the thing
feminism expands the definition of abuse
so we can call everything of you so
that's abuse always Concourse of
controlling he's financially abusing me
getting cheated on is not abuse it's
hurtful it is
um a Miss whatever of trust but can we
stop calling it abuse like this is crazy
oh my goodness it's like
all right
no no okay okay a real abuse short but
cheating no get give me the evidence
because from the what I've seen
there ain't there is nothing worse than
putting a kid in a single mother home
okay how do you know
that man won't abuse the child in the
same way
cheating cheating you don't find the
stats on that
you're making claim
if you are bringing a claim to me you
need to bring the stats Jesus all right
this child will be affected by his
father's abuse of his mother that's for
sure no no and this is what women do
they say oh well what if the kids find
out why did you let the kids find out
why are you letting the kids into your
marital problems the kids should not
know about this and this is wrong it is
wrong for you to bring in even if your
husband's cheating on you whatever like
let's not talk about the [__] that the
women do too women have open social
media accounts women cheat on their
husbands too women accept attention from
other men it's like act like you've
never flirted with another guy in a man
come on all right so it just irritates
me because it's like we have this oh the
women did nothing and if the man does it
he's abusive
this is the okay
and unfortunately the my the child may
turn into an abuser himself okay let's
talk about abusers 80 of great victims
are from single mother homes
the most likely situation for that child
to be an abuser is if he's in a single
mother home
and okay how bad okay imagine you're in
a contract where the woman can take
everything if she leaves
um she also can take your kids away from
you it is a bad contract for men so the
man signs this contract his home life
has to be so bad
if he's seeking out other women it's not
easy for men to get laid all right so
were you berating him were you always
nitpicking at him were you doing things
to make him not feel like a man like
were you denying him sex like we never
talk about this we can't even have this
conversation
um and it's like her immediate reaction
to a cheater is abuser abuser that's not
true
a guy can be a great father and like
some hoes okay can we just call and this
is what I cannot stand you cannot have
this conversation with Christians for
whatever reason and
I'm Pro I'm Pro church I'm Pro like
genuinely I pray to God
um
I think church is a great thing I think
it's great for kids to grow up in I went
to Catholic school I'm really thankful
for that but this immediate Defense of
Women in church is really tiring and
it's really tiring to people that are
actually like Believers like this
immediate oh the woman is always
correct like she didn't contribute
anything to this
um okay
uh okay
for women in a situation like this to
seek out a true Christian man would be
the child's father figure and because
infidelity is grounds for divorce leave
the abuser
I swear I thought in that John chapter
it said if a guy marries another girl's
wife
it's like it's infidelity am I wrong and
okay but again
you're not convincing anyone that
cheating is a small relational problem
it's the most egregious relational
offense and betrayal my question is can
it be a small thing as women
can we because it's only a big thing
think about this
it is only a big thing if we make it a
big thing now again cheating is wrong I
don't believe in cheating Affairs any of
that stuff it's wrong okay but if we're
coming into marriage without any Purity
any youth any loyalty any beauty really
anymore
can you blame the men
I mean and that's my thing it's like
okay you got cheated on well are you in
shape for your husband let's start there
um okay were you berating your husband
every time he got home let's start there
um okay were you doing were you
submissive to your husband let's start
there
were you giving him sex whenever he
wanted let's start there now if the
answer is yes to all four of those
things okay maybe he's just a Serial
cheater but we can't even ask those
questions without me being labeled as
advocating for cheating with me without
me being labeled as encouraging cheating
we can never talk about that so you know
let me know what you guys think maybe
I'm just insane but I do have the
audacity to talk about this and I will
continue to talk about it so if you guys
don't like it then you can just
unsubscribe because I will continue to
speak about these things so like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell talk
to you next time